produced with exclusive support from
Illumina a decade ago scientists broke
down the three billion letters in an
average human genome now they're trying
to translate those letters into a
comprehensive instruction manual for
building a person this book is the
result of the draft human genome it was
a great achievement back in 2000 but
it's just a set of boring letters AC T
mg and it goes on for a very long time
and what encode is trying to do is its
bring this to life these letters
actually do something they mean
something and encode is the project that
starts together this starts to try and
find some understanding for these
letters the aim of the encode project is
to characterize all functional elements
within the human genome and the
consortium considers functional elements
in very broad terms so these include the
genes as we know them the elements in
the genome that encode proteins but also
all transcripts so all of the RNA that
comes off of the genome and very
importantly the project's aims to
characterize the regulatory parts of the
genome sometimes their elements that
switch genes on and off sometimes their
elements that pack up bits of DNA in
appropriate ways and they're probably
things that we have no idea what they're
doing and yet they're doing something
important the encode project has taken
five years it's involved hundreds of
people 400 on the main paper many more
across the other papers and it's
generated hundreds of terabytes of raw
data now that's a pretty large amount of
data but it's actually staggering not
only in its size but its detail one of
the fundamental things about making a
creature as complicated as asses that
were made of many many different types
of cells and those different cells use
different parts of the genome and it's
always been a bit mysterious but what is
it that switches things on and off now
what encode does for a hundred odd
200-300 different cell types is start to
try and understand
why is it your liver cell that's
different from your kidney cell and so
it's really a first view of that
complexity that generates a human being
striking overall the result that the
encode project reports is that they can
assign a function a biochemical function
to 80% of the human genome the reason
why this is striking is because not such
a long time ago we still considered that
vast proportion of the human genome was
simply junk because of course we know
that it's only 3% that encodes proteins
it's very hard to get over the density
of information I think previously people
thought that the genome was quite a
well-organized place with these these
genes that had kind of discrete places
and a discrete quite sedate choreography
but that's just not what the data says
the data it's like a jungle of of stuff
out there there are things that we we
thought we understood and yet it's much
much more complex and then places of the
genome that we thought were completely
silent and they're teeming with life
they're teeming with things going on we
still really don't understand that but
there's this big shift towards towards
this detail and scale Human Genetics
has told us quite a bit about where
areas which areas of the genome are
associated with human disease the
frustration has been that most of these
areas for in non-coding parts of the
genome these are parts of the genome
which we knew until now very little
about and this is exactly where the
encode project comes in you can now work
from the encode starting point and ask
much more focused questions on precisely
why is it that this particular set of
genes seem to do something in the liver
what is switching it on and switching it
off and in particular when it comes to
disease you may in fact not know the
cell type that you are interested in and
encoder lets you find the cell type that
is more associated with your disease
produced with exclusive support from
Illumina